Das ist so langsam der absolute Wahnsinn,
was da um den Artikel 13 und die restlichen
Regelung der Reform des europäischen Urheberrechts
passiert. Erst werden wir Aktivisten von der
Merke EU Kommission als Mob bezeichnet und
jetzt kommt immer mehr heraus, wie hier die
Konzernlobbyisten die Europapolitik an der
Nase herumführt und instrumentalisiert. Das
ist wirklich traurig und lässt einen schon
zweifeln. Dieses Video kommt auf diesem Kanal,
weil er durch die Urheberrechtsreform in besonderem
Maße betroffen wäre. Herzlich willkommen
zu Clixoom Social & Media.
Ja, dieses Video kommt hier, weil es Clixoom
vielleicht so in Zukunft nicht mehr geben.
Unsere Videos enthalten nämlich Unmengen
an Videoausschnitte, Zitaten und Fotos, die
genau durch die Änderung des europäischen
Urheberrerchts betroffen wären. Denn wenn
jemand in einem Upload das gleiche Material
verwendet und als seines deklariert, dann
kann Clixoom seine Videos nicht mehr veröffentlichen.
YouTueb müsste sie sperren. Zwar behauptet
das EU-Parlament in einem Video, dass Zitate,
Memes, Persiflagen, Kritik und Parodie möglich
wären, doch auf der anderen Seite fordern
die neuen Regeln, dass Portale den Upload
von urheberrehctlich geschützten Materilka
verhindern und vor allem dafür haften. Hier
der Ausschnitt:
Dieser Ausschnitt in diesem Video wird in
Zukunft dazu führen, dass das Video gesperrt
wird. Denn er ist ja Content des EU-Parlaments.
Ich habe ihn zwar erlaubter Weise als Zitat
verwendet, aber wie soll das ein Poartal wie
YouTube erkennen? Ganz einfach: Es geht nicht.
Es kann nur einen Uploadfilter verwenden,
alles macht keinen Sinn. Und es muss in restriktiv
verwenden, ansonsten drohen hohe Zahlungen.
Eine eigentlich verbotene Zensur findet statt.
Für Tim Berners-Lee dem Erfinder des World
Wide Web ist es „ein beispielloser Schritt
auf dem Weg zur Transformation des Internets
von einer offenen Plattform für Austausch
und Innovation zu einem Instrument für die
automatisierte Überwachung und Kontrolle
seiner Nutzer “ Das klingt bei der EU noch
ganz anders und die Digitalpolitiker in Deutschland,
selbst die in der CDU, halten es für kompletten
Schwachsinn! Warum? Hier wird die Haftung
von den eigentlichen Tätern, die das Urheberrecht
verletzten könnten, auf den technischen Dienstleister
zur Übertragung der Inhalte übertragen.
Da wird der Bote für den Inhalt haftbar gemacht.
Demnächst haftet dann auch der Satelittenbetreiber
Astra für das schlechte Programm von RTL
oder die Bundesrepublik Deutschland für Unfälle
auf ihren Autobahn oder die Post für Erpresserbriefe
undsoweiterundsofort. Es macht also überhaupt
keinen Sinn. Einfach keinen. Zudem werden
die Urheberrechte zum Beispiel auf YouTube
schon umfassend wahrgenommen. Jede Musik auf
der Plattform wird minutiös registriert und
die Urheber bekommen Geld. Bei jedem Video
werden 50% der Einnahmen ausbezahlt. Ein nicht
ganz unfairer Deal, denn wer schonmal versucht
hat eine eigene Videoplattform zu betreiben,
weiß dass die Technik normalerweise 100%
der Kosten verschlingt. Da können einzige
deutsche Betreiber ein Lied von singen. Und
wem hilft es also? Zum Beispiel der GEMA.
Bie ihren Klagen gegen YouTube, haben die
Gerichte immer die Rechtauffassung vertreten,
dass YouTueb eine Plattform sei und damit
nicht haftbar ist. Mit dem neuen recht kann
die GEMA nun endlich erfolgreich gegen YouTueb
klagen. Manche meinen auch erpressen und mehr
als die 50% rausdrücken. Ich will hier nicht
YouTube/Google verteidigen. Sie sollen einfach
mal sagen, was sie verdienen. Dann hat man
eine vernünftige Verhandlungsgrundlage. Aber
die Haftung deshalb auf den Betreiber der
Infrastruktur zu übertragen, dass ist einfach
ein billiger Taschenspielertrick. Und es nützt
natürlich den großen Medienkonzernen. Die
können sich jetzt wieder mit den verschiedenen
Artikeln 11 und 12 sind da noch wichtig, wieder
als Türsteher dazwischen wanzen und die Ueheber
abkassieren. Denn wir sind eigentlich zufrieden.
Wir wollen die großzügige Nutzung unserer
Werke und dafür eine angemessene Vergütung.
Ich kann davon ein Lied singen und habe deshalb
oft mit YouTube gesprochen. Fast 10 Jahre
lang und Anfang 2017 hat es endlich gefruchtet.
Qualitativ hochwertige Inhalte werden inzwischen
deutlich besser vergütet. Aber die Konzerne
verfolgen hier andere Ziele. Sie wollen ein
Sück vom Kuchen abhaben. Und sie gehen dabei
unglaublich perfide vor. Wie die Europaabgeordnete
Julia Rede von den Piraten herausgefunden
hat, wurde das Jubelvideo….
Von
der AFP, der Agence France Press produziert,
also der DPA Frankreichs. Moment. Die DPA
Frankreichs dreht im Auftrag des Europäischen
Parlaments Propagandavideos über Richtlinien,
die noch gar nicht verabschiedet worden sind?
What? Wenn die Propaganda machen dürfen wir
das schon lange. Wir sind Herr auch Aktivisten
und machen das deutlich während die eigentlich
Volksvertreteerr sind. Haben sie wohl schon
vergessen. Also macht mit Bruno Kramm unabhängiger
Musiker, der hinter den Demos in Berlin steht,
hat eine super Idee. Macht Fahnen mit dem
Hashtag, Plakate und was auch immer mit dem
hashtag #no13 Wir
müssen gegen die Kampagne dagegenhalten und
wir haben es am Montag schon gezeigt, als
wir die CDU dazu gebracht haben öffentlich
einzuknicken und das undemokratische Vorziehen
der Abstimmung vor unsere Demos am 23.März
öffentlich abzusagen. Deshalb lasst uns dranbleiben.
Mehr und aktuellere Infos gibt es immer auf
meinem kanal Clixoom Social & Media, auf dem
ich über diese Themen berichte. Hier abonnieren
und schaut euch auch gerne die Berichte über
das Treffen mit Axel Voss an und weiter Videos.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!